would you do a versus yes you would do
it yes
oh i see that all right is there anybody
that you would do it again so you just
ready for anybody
nikki nikki did she say nikki
yep she did on the red carpet at the
2021 bet awards
little kim announced to the world that
she would like to do a versus battle
against nicki minaj nikki really
i would love to see that yes me too
created by swiss beats and timberland
versus is a friendly competition where
fans can watch r
b and hip hop greats go head to head
with their biggest hits in real time
on social media
what makes this such a big deal is the
fact that kim and nikki
have a long-standing beef well maybe
there is a feud
a beef that dates back over a decade i
had to get everybody around
in the past little kim has accused nikki
of not paying homage to her as a female
rapper
and taking subliminal shots in 2010
nicki responded to kim's
accusations by saying quote put your
music out and when i see your name on
billboard
that's when i'll respond to you adding
quote you're going to go down in history
now as a sore loser
well you have to wait and see over the
years two have had multiple back and
forths
that included disc songs and public
comments
when it spoke to little kim in 2018 she
refused to acknowledge nikki
but gave love to cardi b you are one of
the
og women rappers i grew up listening to
you what do you make of
cardi b and nicki minaj party is that
girl i don't know the other one
cardi is my girl well if this versus
battle happens it will not be the first
time that the series created a space
for artists who have issues with each
other in 2010
rappers jeezy and gucci mane finally
made amends on the verge of stage
after years of being at odds hey man
listen all respect i appreciate you for
all
for throwing out the olive branch i
accept that no disrespect it's all love
love
that's what it is while we wait for
nicki's response
it's clear that this would be one of the
most anticipated versus battles
ever in the meantime little cam opened
up about the importance of paying homage
to queen latifah
who received the lifetime achievement
award at sunday's ceremony
first of all latifa paved the way for
me artists like myself i'm sorry
um so she and she's like my sister
a friend everything she's always been
there for me
um she was strong she was representing
the black woman the way woman's supposed
to be represented
her music spoke for herself her power
spoke for itself
and for her to be like the first black
woman in the game to own her own record
label
and to kind of be a boss and have
artists was like
that was amazing like latifah you're
just everything